...
Roulement de tambour
Musique militaire solennelle
...
-On ne fait plus attention à eux,
pas plus qu'aux panneaux
de signalisation
ou aux poteaux électriques.
...
Ils ornent les places de village,
ils sont au pied de la mairie,
ils décorent le chevet des églises.
...
Ces sentinelles,
c'est comme un musée invisible,
ouvert à tous vents.
...
Deux ou trois fois l'an, on vient
y déposer des gerbes de fleurs.
...
Les monuments aux morts
de la Grande Guerre
ont fini par se mélanger au paysage.
...
A ceux de 14,
on a ajouté d'autres plaques.
Les morts de 40, les résistants,
les déportés...
Tous se confondent.
Et puis, ceux d'Indochine,
d'Algérie, d'ailleurs.
...
Il reste encore un peu de place,
au cas où.
La musique s'adoucit.
Les pauvres soldats
de l'armée morte
ont donné leur vie.
Qu'au moins, on vénère leurs noms.
Croassement
Un train passe au loin.
...
Pour la première fois,
c'est systématique :
les guerriers inconnus
ont le droit
d'être nommés, et pas seulement
les chefs de guerre.
Des oiseaux chantent.
...
Les simples soldats,
les sous-officiers
et les officiers
sont logés à la même enseigne.
Les paysans, les ouvriers,
les citadins,
les pauvres et les riches :
tous les contingents d'hommes
envoyés au feu.
Un coq chante au loin.
Noms inoubliables,
dont on ne se souvient pas.
Les mêmes, souvent,
jusqu'à six
ou sept fois :
les frères, les fils, les pères,
les oncles, les cousins.
Une cloche sonne.
...
La pierre est gorgée de sang.
Des oiseaux chantent.
...
D'Asnières à Salon-de-Provence,
de Verdun à Pessac,
de Nîmes à Amiens...
Les héros ordinaires méritent
maintenant d'entrer dans un panthéon
qui doit se répandre partout
à travers la France.
...
C'est de la frénésie.
Chacune des 36 000 communes
veut son monument.
Sauf que la France est exsangue.
Le quotidien L'Humanité se désolera
en voyant que l'Allemagne
rechigne à payer
ses dommages de guerre :
"Nous n'avons ni pierres,
ni mortier, ni argent, ni maçons
"pour construire des choses
propres à abriter les vivants.
"Mais nous érigeons,
dans toutes les localités
de France et de Navarre,
"tant de monuments
qu'on pourrait bâtir une ville
"avec ces matériaux gaspillés."
"Elève-t-on des monuments
"à la lèpre ?" se désespèrent
certains camarades de tranchées,
effrayés qu'on puisse glorifier
la guerre et les grandes batailles.
Pourtant,
la majorité des associations
d'anciens combattants
poussent à la roue.
Les poilus, démobilisés,
demandent que l'on honore
les morts
mais aussi les vivants,
qui s'entraident
et qui veulent être récompensés
pour ce qu'ils ont fait.
Qu'on ne les oublie pas.
Musique militaire douce
...
Il est vrai
que les anciens combattants
sont une force
avec laquelle il faut compter.
C'est près de la moitié
du corps électoral.
...
Seuls les grands monuments érigés
sur les champs de bataille
le sont à l'initiative de l'Etat.
Le tonnerre gronde.
...
Au contraire,
la charge de la construction
de tous les autres
monuments aux morts
revient aux municipalités.
L'Etat se contente
d'accorder une petite subvention.
Elle est calculée en fonction
du nombre de soldats morts
par rapport au nombre
d'habitants de la commune.
Des oiseaux chantent.
...
C'est insuffisant.
On organise des bals payants,
des séances de cinématographe,
des concerts,
des ventes de charité,
une corrida,
même la quête,
dans certaines paroisses.
Il n'est pas rare
que la presse locale publie
le nom des bienfaiteurs
et le montant de leur don.
C'est un encouragement certain.
...
Des cloches sonnent.
Des oiseaux chantent.
...
Un comité est constitué spécialement
dans chaque commune
pour suivre les étapes
du projet.
Le maire doit négocier,
défendre ses préférences
mais aussi obtenir l'assentiment
du plus grand nombre,
celui des familles.
Les familles des morts
pour la France
comme celles des démobilisés,
dont il faut éviter les jalousies.
...
On est invité à aller voir
les plans ou la maquette,
à la mairie ou chez l'épicier,
pour donner son avis,
car l'oeuvre à créer doit être
"l'oeuvre de tous",
selon l'expression du maire
de Châteauneuf-la-Forêt.
Musique sautillante
...
Le chantier qui s'annonce
offre du travail.
Il incite les différents
corps de métier
et les petits artisans,
sans parler des intermédiaires,
à se disputer le marché
auprès des municipalités.
Terrassiers, maçons, carriers,
fondeurs, ferronniers,
tailleurs de pierre
et même architectes et sculpteurs
pour les édifices
plus originaux.
Roulement de tambour
Musique militaire douce
...
Le bruit des marteaux et des ciseaux
retentit à travers le pays
tout au long des années 20
et jusqu'à la fin des années 30.
...
De nombreuses communes
font de l'origine
locale ou départementale
des sculpteurs
une condition
de leur appel d'offres.
...
Ainsi, Donzelli, artisan
venu d'Italie avec ses fils,
qui s'est installé
pour trouver du travail
dans les régions sinistrées
de l'est de la France.
...
En rendant hommage aux soldats
de Lacroix-sur-Meuse
et aux habitants morts
pendant la guerre
- le village a été presque
intégralement détruit -,
Donzelli utilise peut-être aussi
la pierre pour remercier le pays
qui l'a accueilli
et donner libre cours à sa gratitude
envers les femmes et les hommes
de la commune.
...
Ailleurs, on est fier de solliciter
des célébrités de la capitale,
des sculpteurs prestigieux.
Prix de Rome, membres
de l'Académie des beaux-arts,
anciens élèves
de l'atelier de Frémiet,
de Carpeaux,
de Dalou ou de Rodin.
Y a-t-il eu un tel projet
depuis les cathédrales ?
Musique douce
...
Des entreprises,
qui s'étaient spécialisées
dans les statues de la République
ou les bustes de Marianne,
le culte des grands hommes
et des petits notables,
se convertissent dans la production
en série de monuments aux morts.
Les marbreries funéraires,
les bronziers, les fonderies
offrent sur catalogue
des stèles, des obélisques,
des colonnes tronquées,
lauriers, palmes,
couronnes, coqs gaulois, etc.
Des effigies sortent en quantité
du même moule :
près de 800 exemplaires
du poilu modèle Camus,
en une seule taille de 1,60 mètre,
patiné imitation pierre de taille
ou imitation bronze,
en ciment dur inaltérable,
aussi résistant que le granit,
ou peint en couleur naturelle
bleu horizon, à la demande.
Les exemplaires produits en série
sont bien meilleur marché
que les oeuvres originales.
Dans son premier roman,
le jeune
Alexandre Vialatte
imagine, en 1928, le personnage
d'un représentant de commerce.
-"Il y a encore plus
"de communes qu'on ne pense
qui n'ont pas
"leur monument aux morts.
On n'a pas compris
"ce qu'il leur faut.
"On leur propose la France
avec des ailes,
"la victoire
avec des nichons pointus,
"des pyramides
"de casques,
des faisceaux de baïonnettes
"et des tas de choses
"allégoriques.
Et l'art, que je dis au maire,
"en le regardant bien en face,
"ils s'en foutent,
ils veulent leur poilu !
"Alors voilà, je leur fais
des poilus en série.
"Suivant les villages,
je leur colle le numéro
"du régiment dans lequel
ils ont servi presque tous.
"Ils ne voient plus que ça
dans la statue,
"ça leur fait plus plaisir
qu'une belle femme
"comme les réclames
pour le Pétrole Hahn.
"Tu fignoles les molletières,
les boutons, le sac,
"la musette,
la grenade du casque...
"Servez chaud,
c'est du pain vendu !
"Ils se reconnaissent :
"'Ca, c'est nous,
c'est comme ça que nous étions !'
Musique grandiose
...
"J'appris ainsi
pourquoi les villages
"s'ornaient inexcusablement
d'une belle floraison
"de poilus raides
comme des tuyaux de gouttière
"et pimpants comme des mannequins.
"Si ce n'était pas un triomphe
"de la sculpture, c'était du moins
une victoire de la psychologie.
Explosion
"Majorité réactionnaire ?
"J'offre le modèle numéro 4,
le poilu
"debout, invincible, victorieux.
"Majorité rouge ?
"Je préconise le 4 bis,
le soldat mourant,
"le cadavre,
la guerre sans compensation."
Musique lugubre
...
-Dans la pierre
ou la fonte,
on donne des leçons d'héroïsme,
on met en scène
l'exaltation patriotique,
les tambours et les trompettes,
le vieux sang séché.
"On ne passe pas !",
crient les soldats
aux bras tendus,
qui, ainsi postés,
auraient offert une cible parfaite.
Musique enlevée
...
Ultime représentation du théâtre
aux armées.
...
L'ennemi est hors champ.
Comme dans les tranchées,
l'ennemi ne se montre pas.
Au mieux, un casque à pointe,
un casque pris dans les barbelés.
Au pire, un aigle immense abattu
aux pieds d'un soldat.
...
Le temps est suspendu,
le drap tombe d'un coup
et la statue apparaît.
Musique grave
...
L'inauguration est la fête rituelle
de l'entre-deux-guerres.
Année après année,
les discours s'adressent
aux monuments aux morts,
comme aux dieux protecteurs
de la cité.
Défilent les corps constitués
et les enfants des écoles.
La Marseillaise jouée en fond.
Le monument devient le centre
autour duquel gravite
la vie locale.
...
La victoire a lieu
dans chaque commune.
...
La République honore
le sacrifice de ses soldats.
La République console
ses enfants
en proclamant
qu'ils ne sont pas morts pour rien.
La presse nationaliste lance
une virulente campagne
en avril 1927
pour interdire l'inauguration
du monument de Levallois-Perret.
Elle s'insurge
que la guerre y soit montrée
comme une chose horrible.
Croassement de corbeau
Musique mélancolique douce
Le Populaire,
le quotidien dirigé
par Léon Blum,
se félicite au contraire
d'y voir un des mutinés
fusillés pour l'exemple...
...
...et que soit figuré
un tirailleur
des troupes d'Afrique
victimes de la colonisation.
...
Au centre,
un soldat gazé,
à l'agonie.
...
Le préfet de la Seine veut
réconcilier les points de vue.
"N'est-ce pas plutôt
sa compassion immense
"qu'exprime le sculpteur,
Charles Yrondi,
"envers les tortures
morales et physiques
"endurées stoïquement
par les poilus
"au service
de la patrie meurtrie ?",
explique-t-il dans son discours.
...
Quant à l'ouvrier,
qui attire toute la polémique,
brise-t-il son glaive ?
"C'est l'une des armes de l'ennemi
ramassées sur le champ de bataille",
justifie encore le préfet.
...
"La paix retrouvée, n'est-il pas
temps de jeter ses armes ?"
...
L'artiste, Yrondi,
un ancien combattant valeureux,
se défend
de toute inspiration subversive.
"Il fut quand même
bien imprudent",
déplore le journal
de l'Union nationale
des combattants,
"d'en appeler à l'imagination
des spectateurs,
"au risque
de prêter son oeuvre
"à toutes les interprétations."
Musique émouvante douce
...
Coup de canon au loin
Parmi les sculpteurs, beaucoup
étaient en âge de partir combattre
sur le front ou de rejoindre
des unités de camouflage.
Maintenant, ils veulent
témoigner pour leurs camarades.
Les plus novateurs veulent
simplifier, frapper.
Etre moderne,
ce peut être simplement
refuser l'allégorie
ou le style épique,
chercher à être vrai.
Musique militaire douce
...
L'on peut lire dans le numéro
de juillet 1922 du magazine
Art et Décoration
ce compliment sur une statue
de Meurthe-et-Moselle :
"Rien de brutal dans ce guerrier
"dont la guerre n'est
ni la profession ni l'idéal.
"Il est viril, sans violence.
"Il reste alerte
"sous l'épaisse capote
"et il garde,
jusque dans la boue des tranchées,
"une élégance native."
...
C'est presque toujours le soldat
qui a abandonné
son élégant képi
en beaux draps de l'été 1914
qui est représenté.
Il n'a plus sa tenue bleu
et garance,
d'un rouge merveilleux
pour les mitrailleuses allemandes.
Il porte enfin l'uniforme
que l'on sait bleu horizon
et le casque Adrian.
Il a fallu attendre
le printemps 1915
pour que sa tête
soit un peu protégée.
Mais ne sont pas trop montrés
les bidons de pinard ou de gnole,
ce qui aidait les fantassins
à jaillir de la tranchée
à l'attaque
de celle d'en face,
quelques dizaines
de mètres plus loin.
Tirs en rafales
et détonations au loin
...
Benjamin Simonet est capitaine
d'un régiment d'infanterie.
Chaque jour ou presque, il écrit
à sa femme depuis le début
de la guerre.
-"Ma chérie,
"il a fallu d'abord franchir
"un terrain découvert
d'environ 400 mètres,
"battu par les balles.
"Ce n'était rien encore.
"Du point le plus dangereux,
"un boyau d'une centaine
de mètres conduisait
"à la tranchée.
"Au fond, une boue épaisse
"dans laquelle
nous enfonçons jusqu'aux genoux.
"Quel supplice !
"Ces 100 mètres
m'ont paru des kilomètres.
"Enfin, nous voici arrivés,
"jambes et pieds trempés,
"immondes,
"mes effets couverts
d'une couche de boue collante.
"Si vous m'aviez vu !
"Enfin, je prépare l'attaque,
"transmets mes ordres,
juste à temps, car bientôt,
"l'artillerie donna
d'une façon intense.
"Nos hommes sont tassés,
baïonnette au canon,
"dans la tranchée.
"Malheureusement,
"aucun gradin préparé.
"Le talus est haut
de près de 2 mètres.
"La terre, glissante.
"Je donne un coup de sifflet
à 7h45.
"Quelques braves,
gradés en tête,
"grimpent
d'une centaine de mètres.
"Aussitôt,
"des mitrailleuses ennemies
déclenchent leurs tirs.
"Quelques-uns tombent
près de la tranchée,
"la plupart gagnent un talus
à 30 mètres de là et s'y couchent.
Musique militaire intrigante
"Ceux-ci partis,
"l'élan est fini.
"J'ai beau supplier,
"crier,
"taper à coups de pied,
"sortir mon revolver,
"les hommes ne veulent pas
quitter la tranchée.
"Quelques-uns essaient.
"Je les fais hisser par les pieds
pour qu'ils aillent plus vite.
"A peine arrivent-ils au sommet
pour prendre leur élan et courir,
"une balle les frappe
et ils retombent,
"tués ou blessés.
"L'attaque est ratée.
"Toute la journée ainsi.
"Tu comprends pourquoi hier
je ne t'ai pas écrit."
...
-Les monuments sont la manière
moderne de pratiquer l'alchimie.
Ils transmutent en dur
la chair.
Ils solidifient les corps
par le calcaire,
mais aussi le marbre blanc,
la fonte ou le bronze,
l'agglomérat
de poudre de roche,
le béton armé.
Mais le fer à l'intérieur
peut rouiller.
Il faut des aciers
mêlés de cuivre,
et c'est plus cher.
Le granit en Bretagne
ou dans les Vosges.
Le grès rose en Alsace.
La pierre de lave en Auvergne.
Rien ne doit provenir
d'Allemagne,
ni matériaux
ni main d'oeuvre.
Piaillements d'oiseaux
...
Les voici maintenant,
les sculpteurs
qui attrapent des choses vues.
Musique mélancolique douce
...
Les monuments fixent
en volume et en relief
ce que personne
ne pouvait voir loin du front.
...
Les sculpteurs stockent
des gestes.
Ils cachent des souvenirs
au fond de leur statue.
...
De même que les offensives
doivent être reconstituées
pour les actualités filmées,
la guerre est rejouée
par les monuments.
...
Le spectacle est contemporain
de l'essor du cinématographe...
...
...le passage du muet au parlant.
Les statues sont muettes,
mais elles parlent.
...
Si ce jeune soldat se bouche
les oreilles, c'est que la guerre,
en permanence, fait un boucan
de tous les diables.
Acouphène
...
Les statues sont
toujours dressées,
érigées.
Seuls les bas-reliefs
gravés sur le socle,
comme des photographies
imprimées dans la pierre,
montrent que les soldats
ont vécu enfouis,
enterrés dans la terre.
Musique grave
...
Tout y est,
jusqu'aux parapets,
aux paniers en osier,
aux sacs de sable.
Le froid,
le terrassement,
le poste de guet,
l'attaque des gaz,
le souffle des tirs de canon,
l'explosion soudaine,
le compte à rebours
juste avant l'assaut.
Le tonnerre gronde.
Quelque chose d'implacable,
la guerre
réduite à l'essentiel :
la vie,
la guerre,
la mort,
l'attente,
l'abrutissement.
Grondements
...
Détonation
En une suite d'instantanés,
Gaston Broquet
rend hommage
à ses compagnons d'armes.
Il disperse des bouts de récit
entre Raon-l'Etape,
Bains-les-Bains,
Commercy,
Châlons-en-Champagne,
Samogneux
ou l'hôpital du Val-de-Grâce,
à Paris.
Marcel Bitsch, infirmier
au 94e régiment d'infanterie,
musicien dans le civil, raconte.
-"Roisset me présente
Gaston Broquet,
"sculpteur, soldat à la 7e.
"Grande discussion sur Balzac.
"8 mai :
"le bataillon stationne
à l'entrée du ravin de la Houyette,
"voie d'accès à Bagatelle.
"J'ai l'impression qu'en pleine
attaque, c'est imprudent.
"Rafale d'obus juste sur nous,
pénétrants et fusants.
"Des obus qui tombent
à toute vitesse.
"Tués, blessés, désordre.
"Je me foule la cuisse.
"Un mort :
"Broquet, le sculpteur,
"qui faisait ses débuts
de brancardier, s'affale."
Musique douce
...
-De son côté, Louis Maufrais,
médecin auxiliaire,
consigne le même jour...
-"Nous voyons alors que l'un d'entre
nous ne s'est pas relevé :
"Gaston Broquet, le sculpteur.
"Je suis touché", me dit-il.
"Je ne peux plus bouger."
"Apparemment,
il a un shrapnel dans l'épaule
"et l'une de ses chaussures
est déchirée.
"Je le confie à un brancardier
"pour qu'ils l'emmènent
immédiatement."
...
-Que dire à ceux
qui n'ont jamais rien vu ?
Eugène-Emmanuel Lemercier
combat aux Eparges.
-"Nos pertes sont effroyables,
"celles de l'ennemi, pires encore.
"Tu ne peux pas savoir,
ma mère aimée,
"ce que l'homme
peut faire contre l'homme.
"Voici cinq jours
"que mes souliers sont gras
de cervelle humaine,
"que j'écrase des thorax,
"que je rencontre des entrailles.
"Les hommes mangent
à côté des cadavres.
"Le régiment a été héroïque."
Musique pesante
...
-Le médecin auxiliaire
René Prieur,
le 25 février 1916,
près de Verdun.
-"Le canon de 75 fauche tout.
"Les bras, les têtes,
les membres volent en l'air.
"Je suis éclaboussé de sang.
"Le ravin est comblé de morts
qui s'amoncellent et,
"vers quatre heures et quart,
"quand je me dégage
de ma tranchée et des arbres,
"je ne sais pas où je vais.
"Je n'ai rien vu
de plus infernal.
"J'entendrai toute ma vie
le son métallique du 75,
"les cris des blessés,
"le nombre inouï des morts."
...
-Gaston Broquet, toujours,
ose montrer ce à quoi ressemble
le cadavre tout recroquevillé
d'un simple soldat.
...
Des corbeaux croassent.
A Auchel, dans le Pas-de-Calais,
comme aux Lilas, près de Paris,
le sculpteur Félix Desruelles
ne craint pas non plus
de représenter les morts.
L'un est affalé
sur le ventre,
face contre terre,
l'autre regarde
sans plus rien voir.
"Voyez ce soldat",
explique à ses administrés le maire
d'une commune du Puy-de-Dôme,
"voyez cette face convulsée
par la douleur :
"ce n'est pas un héros victorieux,
"c'est un paysan de chez nous
"qui est allé jusqu'aux limites
de ce qu'on peut souffrir."
Ce corps affaissé,
cette tête penchée,
ce visage amaigri,
ce regard qui s'éteint,
cet épuisement,
cette grande détresse,
tout cela dit au passant
les horreurs de la guerre.
Certains sculpteurs
sont les disciples de Goya,
de Jéricho.
Ils sont embarqués
sur le Radeau de la Méduse.
Musique pesante
...
Si l'on veut échapper
au réalisme brutal,
au tragique,
aux scènes de la vie du soldat,
comment concevoir
une forme de monument
à la mesure
de la démesure de la guerre,
à la hauteur de la mort de masse ?
Musique solennelle
Comme à Lyon,
dans l'île du Souvenir,
certains adeptes de l'Art déco
en appellent en dernier recours
à l'Antiquité,
à ses mythologies.
...
Leurs sculptures
sont proprement monumentales.
Elles portent le poids
de la catastrophe,
le catafalque de la guerre.
...
Mais les communes
ne sont pas très enclines
à se tourner vers les courants
de l'avant-garde,
qu'elles jugent souvent décadents
et ces artistes redoutent
de travailler sous contrôle.
...
Maintenant, il faut
refermer la lourde porte,
ainsi, à Vierzon.
...
Pour faire que la Grande Guerre
soit la "der des ders",
la dernière des guerres,
il ne reste plus
qu'à mobiliser les Titans.
...
Pendant qu'il travaille
à la maquette en plâtre
de son grand monument,
Paul Landowski tient son journal.
"17 octobre 1919.
"Rue de Valois.
"Au ministère, M. Moullé me demande
toutes sortes de renseignements :
"prix du modèle,
prix de l'exécution,
"quel titre donner à mon groupe.
"Le titre que je lui donnerai,
ce sera 'Les fantômes',
"mais pour la commande,
il ne faut effrayer personne.
"Nous l'appellerons 'Les morts'.
"2 décembre 1921.
"L'ami Bouglé m'a donné 3 heures,
ce matin,
"pour la tête
de 'L'homme à la pioche'.
"Je n'ai pas perdu ces 3 heures,
"travaillé l'après-midi
"au bras droit
de 'L'homme à la pioche',
"avec Ledrevo.
"Je fais apparaître
un morceau de bras nu
"sous la manche
de la capote déchirée.
"7 décembre 1921,
"fais mouler les mains
du jeune soldat Le Bohec
"pour 'L'homme au fusil'.
"J'y suis,
je prends de plus en plus possession
"de mon groupe
"et mon groupe prend de plus en plus
possession de moi.
"15 novembre 1923.
"Je simplifie de plus en plus
la présentation des 'Fantômes'.
"Quand on arrive à une solution
simple, très simple,
"qui fait presque dire :
'Ce n'était pas bien malin,
"'il n'y avait pas autre chose
à faire'", on peut être content,
"mais seuls les artistes
peuvent se douter
"du mal qu'on a eu pour arriver
à ce résultat,
"et par quel détour on y est arrivé.
"J'ai tout simplement aligné
côte à côte,
"comme ils l'étaient
dans leurs vies de soldats,
"comme ils le sont maintenant
dans les fosses où ils dorment.
"'Les morts'.
"Ils se redressent
autour de ces grands spectres.
"La terre s'entrouvre.
"Ils réapparaissent debout.
"Un peu incertains, les yeux clos",
dit Paul Landowski.
Musique solennelle
...
Achevé enfin en 1935,
le groupe des "Fantômes",
- chaque figure de granit
atteint 8 mètres de hauteur -
orne la butte de Chalmont,
où avait eu lieu
la seconde bataille de la Marne
à l'été 1918.
...
Corps sans nom.
Noms sans corps.
Les disparus sont des morts
qui n'ont pas laissé de traces
de leur anéantissement.
Des fantômes,
ceux que l'on considère
comme des demi-morts,
n'ont aucune sépulture.
Ils n'en finissent pas
de rôder.
Ces morts
sont d'autant plus angoissants
que l'on peut continuer malgré tout
à espérer leur retour à la vie.
Même défigurés,
même inconscients,
même amnésiques.
Les faits divers de l'époque,
comme les romans, en sont peuplés.
Musique grave
...
Combien de soldats
sont restés inconnus ?
Rien que du côté français,
un rapport parlementaire a évalué,
au lendemain
de la guerre,
leur nombre à plus de 300 000,
mais en réalité, c'est bien plus.
Un mort sur quatre
ou un mort sur trois
n'a pu être identifié.
Comment être exact,
alors que les soldats disparus
ressortent encore aujourd'hui
des entrailles de la terre ?
Musique solennelle
...
Qu'attendre désormais ?
Maxime Real del Sarte,
- le sculpteur a perdu un bras
aux Eparges -
veut croire, lui, que la mort
est un passage vers l'au-delà,
le prélude à la résurrection
des corps.
...
Pas de symboles religieux
sur les monuments,
pour ne pas risquer
de raviver la querelle
de la séparation
de l'Eglise et de l'Etat,
mais beaucoup de ruses,
y compris la croix de guerre,
qui sert de croix de substitution.
...
Jeanne d'Arc, la Vierge guerrière,
a été canonisée en 1920 par le pape,
et puis par la République.
...
De manière à peine voilée,
le récit de la passion
offre un modèle parfait.
...
Il sert à évoquer à mots couverts
le martyre du soldat,
sa descente de croix,
sa déposition,
d'innombrables pietàs.
Combien de mater dolorosa ?
...
Quelque chose de sacré
en oublie le drame abominable.
...
Dernière lettre
d'Edouard Béguin,
lieutenant
au 169e régiment d'infanterie.
-"Ma chère femme.
"Les attaques, les contre-attaques
de part et d'autre
"ne font que tuer les hommes.
"Dans de telles circonstances,
"nous n'avons plus qu'à attendre
la mort.
"Tu embrasseras nos enfants.
"Je te recommande
de veiller à leur éducation,
"si possible de leur faire apprendre
un métier.
"Pour notre René,
"il faut lui faire avoir
son brevet supérieur,
"pour le faire entrer
dans l'école spéciale
"pour les fils des officiers
tués devant l'ennemi.
"En ce qui concerne ta pension,
les assurances,
"les mutuelles, ma solde,
"vois monsieur Chenet,
surveillant de travaux
"à la mairie de Nancy.
"Il t'aidera à régler tout cela.
"Quant à moi,
qui vais reposer avec mes camarades
"au cimetière de Montauville,
"j'aimerais bien être rentré
près de vous tous
"au cimetière de notre village.
"Eh bien, ma chère femme,
"je pense, au moment de mourir,
"que j'ai passé 14 années heureuses
avec toi.
Au revoir, ma chère femme,
"embrasse bien mes pauvres petits.
"Ton mari tué. Edouard."
Musique solennelle
...
-Les monuments
sont des mises en abîme,
des tombeaux.
...
Connu ou inconnu,
enterré dans les cimetières
des champs de bataille,
reposant dans leur village
ou disparu corps et âme,
le mort peut maintenant
revenir à la maison.
...
Celles qui n'ont jamais
pu s'approcher,
elles peuvent enfin arriver.
Les jeunes filles,
les jeunes femmes,
les marraines de guerre,
les épouses,
les veuves en noir
et les fiancées que l'on appelle
"les veuves blanches".
...
La famille peut voir son défunt
une dernière fois.
...
Le gisant est lavé, embaumé, paré,
plus beau mort que vivant,
comme s'il s'était éteint
dans son lit.
La pierre accorde des larmes,
des caresses
et des étreintes que le mort
n'a jamais reçues.
La pierre des monuments
célèbre des funérailles
qui n'ont jamais eu lieu.
Musique solennelle
...
A Lodève, dans l'Hérault,
en guise
de pleureuses modernes,
à l'époque où les femmes
jouent un nouveau rôle
et réclament en vain
leur droit de vote,
quatre élégantes sont habillées
selon la mode des années folles.
Leurs robes, leurs manteaux,
leurs parures, leurs broderies
sont taillés dans un calcaire
coloré à l'acide.
"Il y a deux éléments qui dictent
impérieusement
"les grandes lignes
du monument :
"la lumière directe du soleil
et la disposition du terrain",
répond le sculpteur
Paul Dardé au journal local.
"La question de la lumière
"est très importante.
"C'est elle qui fait jouer
la perspective
"qui la détruit ou l'accentue.
"Pour qu'elle ne soit pas détruite,
cette perspective,
"il faut qu'elle possède
une forte ossature,
"une masse qui ne soit pas
déchiquetée par la lumière.
"D'où la disposition
de ces quatre figures
"sur lesquelles viendront battre
les rayons du soleil.
"Ainsi disposé,
"l'ensemble prendra
un beau caractère d'intimité.
"Un côté du visage est intact,
"comme chez les gisants,
"mais l'autre côté est défiguré,
"par exception.
"Les gueules cassées,
"il faut les laisser errer
dans les rues
"ou les cacher
dans les hôpitaux et les asiles.
"On ne les sculpte pas.
"Ca suffit comme ça,
leur visage cubiste.
"Un amputé, très rarement.
"Aucun cul-de-jatte,
"alors qu'il y a un million
d'invalides
"et d'hommes défigurés,
d'êtres trafiqués par la guerre."
Musique solennelle
...
Applaudissements
Yvonne, 24 ans, apprend
la mort de son mari,
Maurice Retour.
"Je suis brisée.
"Il me semble
que je n'ai plus de coeur
"tant il est broyé
dans ses fibres les plus intimes.
"Quand je songe aux longues années
qui s'ouvrent devant moi,
"je suis prise de vertige.
"Il m'a abandonnée
alors que je n'ai fait
"qu'entrevoir le bonheur
de notre union.
"Du jour au lendemain,
j'apprends que tout est fini,
"sans avoir pu donner
un dernier regard
"à celui que j'aimais plus
que moi-même."
Près de sept ans plus tard,
Yvonne assiste à l'exhumation
du corps de son mari
pour son rapatriement
dans le cimetière
de sa ville de Normandie.
"Ah, si je le revoyais
non pas vivant",
s'exclame-t-elle.
"C'est de la folie d'y songer,
"mais seulement intact."
C'est lui, intact,
le jeune officier
au visage de héros
qu'a sculpté Marcel Pierre
à La Ferté-Macé,
pour exaucer le voeu
de sa jeune épouse.
Quand ils arrivaient en permission,
le plus souvent, les soldats
ne pouvaient rien raconter.
Qu'aurait-on pu comprendre
à leurs histoires ?
Le fracas des explosions
les poursuit.
Leurs rêves sont des cauchemars.
Ils sentent un vide
à la place de leurs pensées.
Musique douce
...
Nombre de ceux
qui sont revenus vivants
font semblant d'être en vie,
absents comme des revenants,
comme des statues.
Une part d'eux
n'en reviendra jamais.
Ils ne répondent pas
aux questions,
muets comme des tombes.
Les enfants portent l'empreinte
de ces silences.
Ils sont pétrifiés.
...
Les petites filles
et les petits garçons
ont beau supplier,
ils sont voués à fêter les héros
pour faire oublier
qu'ils sont
des victimes collatérales.
...
Il y eut 760 000
à 1 million d'orphelins,
on ne sait,
qui s'ajoutent aux 600 000 veuves,
aux parents,
aux frères, aux soeurs,
aux proches
qui ont été atteints.
...
Les monuments ne montrent pas
que la guerre.
Ils ne font pas
que célébrer les héros.
Les statues contiennent
l'endurance,
la résignation, la colère,
la douleur.
Musique mélancolique
...
Ce sont des sarcophages
pour enfouir les chagrins,
pour continuer à se souvenir,
pour parvenir à oublier.
...
Il y a des larmes
dans les choses.
...
-André Pézard,
"Nous autres à Vauquois (1918)".
"Mes amis,
tout cela est fini,
"et maintenant,
vous êtes morts.
"Je m'égare dans mes souvenirs,
et parfois, je ne les reconnais pas
"tellement j'ai changé depuis.
"Mes amis, je vis encore
à toute heure avec vous
"et vous ne savez pas.
"Je deviendrai vieux,
"avec vous
qui serez jeunes.
"Je m'en veux de voir
en ma tristesse
"une chose
qui est tellement mienne.
"Il faudrait oublier
"que c'est moi qui parle,
car c'est vous
"qui en êtes le prix."
"Vous me rendez si triste
"que je ne voudrais même pas
mourir maintenant,
"mais rester
sans plus jamais changer,
"car si je mourais,
toute cette peine,
"qui est votre chose,
serait perdue.
"Laissez-moi dire ceci
lentement,
"comme est lente
une pensée endolorie.
"Laissez-moi dire lentement
comme tombent à regret
"de chères syllabes meurtries...
"Adieu, ma pauvre guerre !
"Et c'est tout.
"Adieu, ma pauvre guerre."
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...